okay hi I'm Stuart print from long now
foundation you know if b612 foundation
working with asteroids didn't exist I
feel like the long now foundation would
have to invent it because it is so much
the kind of thing that we're trying to
encourage in terms of long term thinking
long term action and one of our first
speakers actually nine years ago I think
was in this series was rusty Schweickart
who introduced the subject of detecting
asteroids in thwarting the dangerous
ones
and here we're checking in nine years
later his foundation b612 is not only
alive and well but doing stepping up to
a really major incremental point with
another x astronaut rusty Schweickart
was with apollo i had loose been up on
the Space Science Lab and there's
something about when these characters
get off planet when they come back they
act out of some kind of planetary sense
of responsibility which speaks well for
the ongoing space program because as
more and more people get off planet over
the coming decades and centuries they
may well step up as these guys have to
planetary responsibilities the scale of
these projects to go outside the Earth's
orbit and start looking at a level of
detail that we haven't done before at
basically our whole solar system
neighborhood looking for in that frame
of reference tiny things but tiny
important things which if they are
successful
and finding the dangerous asteroids and
then heading them off that's the case
for this planet as long as humans are
around and keep being able to send
rockets and do gravity tractors and
things like that so this is like a major
shift and it's why I referred to it and
the title is Anthropocene astronomy this
is stepping up to planetary stewardship
at a scale so vast not only in space but
in time that I think we're still getting
used to it and one of the neat things
about it is this very very long term
project as being run by a guy with I
think the shortest name in the world ed
Lu thanks
okay so first off I wanted to thank you
for for coming here tonight it's a real
pleasure to speak here I have always
loved the concept that long now
foundation because at some level
somebody somewhere has to think about
the very very long-term problems we
can't all just be thinking about what's
happening tomorrow what's happening next
week or what's you know the majority of
people do need to do just that
but somebody somewheres needs to
thinking about the long-term problems
because those are the things that really
guide the long-term future of our
civilization and so you know I wanted to
thank the organizers of long now for
allowing me the chance to speak here I
want to start with a little story first
when I first became an astronaut which
was thousand years ago in 1995 they
would bring in astronauts in classes and
we were in that class of 1995 there was
19 of us and they used to bring in the
old-timer astronauts who would come back
to sort of tell us things and just give
us advice and we I had the privilege
then a meeting for the first time Neil
Armstrong he came in and and you know he
just basically sat down and told stories
with us and he and he as a test pilot of
everything from rocket vehicles to you
know flying to the moon he he told us he
goes you know what he goes he goes
here's the way I look at flying things
you know when it comes to making
decisions about things if you're in an
airplane or a rocket or whatnot he goes
and and there's an emergency that
happens you know if it didn't kill you
right away you usually got time to think
about it and what he really meant by
that was that the first thing you know
he said the first thing you really need
to do when you when something happens is
to think about how long do I have to
make a decision I try and think ahead of
just what is the next thing I got to do
okay so that in fact is really what the
long now foundation is about isn't it it
is an attempt to think about not just
you know how do I you know pay the bills
next month or how do I you know what do
I got to do you know next week or even
tomorrow not that you don't need to do
that but reserve those three or four
brain cells to think about you know
what's out there 50 or 100 years so
that's in fact what we're trying to do
so as Stuart said you know what is it
that's really important on long
timescales and on very very long
timescales the things that we find
important today kind of recede off and
the things that are important on very
long time skills include things like
well what if our planet gets smacked
like it has a thousand times in the past
so this is one of my favorite
photographs that I took I took it while
orbiting the Earth in 2003 and it shows
first off for those who might think well
that's kind of odd you know what is it
upside down is it sideways it's not
because if you're in space there is no
up or down so this is the edge of the
Earth's atmosphere and there's the moon
over there up in the blackness of space
it's actually just about to set and I
like this because it sort of
encapsulates one of the things that you
really start to appreciate when you
spend a lot of time up there looking
down at the earth first thing you
realize that the earth is incredibly
beautiful and that it's the only earth
out there it sort of dominates your
field of view and the second thing is
when you look at the moon you look at
all these craters and you say oh you
know it's it's immediately obvious that
what created those craters which are
asteroids running into the moon also hit
the earth and because the Moon and Earth
are basically next to each other in
space whatever is hitting the moon those
things are also hitting the earth and in
fact you can determine how many how
often the earth it gets hurt hit by
Counting craters on the moon and if you
count those things divided by the age of
the moon and account for things like the
fact that there there's some
complications and there but basically
it's not that much more difficult than
that it's actually a project that could
be done by undergraduates you're gonna
have them but looking for counting
craters and dividing right so you can do
how many asteroids hit the earth and so
there isn't a whole lot of dispute about
these numbers they are what they are and
so I like to say well why should we care
about asteroids well you can distill all
those numbers down into into odds and
you can think of us on our planet as
playing a giant game of cosmic roulette
every day we roll the dice are we gonna
get hit by an asteroid or not now
asteroids come in various sizes from big
to small there are craters big to small
there are more small ones than there are
big ones and we could put these you
could boil all that down into the chance
that your children that during your
children's lifetime that the earth will
be hit by an asteroid of a some size
okay so here's where here are the
numbers in your children's lifetime so
let's call it rough until the end of
this century the odds that there will be
a asteroid that will hit the earth
somewhere on the surface of the earth
that's big enough to destroy a major
city it's about 30% now the last time we
had one of those was in 1908 where an
asteroid struck in a place called
Tunguska in Siberia it leveled an area
about the size of the San Francisco Bay
Area from here to San Jose
okay completely obliterated it and and
in the next hundred years there's about
a 30% chance we'll have another one
nobody disputes that now it is true that
most of the earth is unpopulated but
less and less of it is getting to be so
okay so and it sure would be a shame if
the next one landed in an area that was
not unpopulated okay let's talk about
larger ones by the way that asteroid
that did that is about the size of this
room maybe a little bit larger it was
about a hundred and forty hundred fifty
feet across so this is this room is
probably about 80 feet across well think
of something about twice the size of
this room that was big enough to take
out the entire San Francisco Bay Area or
if you'd like the LA basin or you know
Washington DC okay let's talk about a
larger one you know who here has been
over to the baseball park 18 t field
okay so take an asteroid that would fit
easily inside that stadium in fact you
could put several inside that stadium
that size asteroid when they hit
releases about a hundred megatons of
energy now just for scale 100 megatons
doesn't you know it's hard to compute
what is that that is if you took all the
bombs used in World War two including
the nuclear bombs which were tested and
and dropped put them all in one big
place sent them off at the same time
that includes every bullet every
everything that could blow up and
multiply by five that's about the energy
okay so think world war level in terms
of amount of energy okay what are the
chances that that will happen somewhere
on earth during your children's lifetime
it's about 1% now it doesn't sound like
that much but I will guarantee you that
you insure yourself against things that
are far less likely than that okay who
here has fire insurance on their house
who I mean who who owns a house that has
fire insurance on your house why do you
have fire insurance on your house the
chances of your house burned down less
than 1% why it's not very likely right
okay now you you do that because you
can't accept what would happen if it did
happen right you have to insure yourself
against that in the case of our planet
pretty much I don't care where that hits
it's very likely to have global at the
very least economic and political
ramifications let alone if it killed 100
million people okay
and by the way dropping something like
that into the ocean is not a guarantee
that it could be worse because you can
get tsunamis okay so 1% interesting huh
so this really is cosmic roulette right
we won yesterday we don't know if we're
gonna win tomorrow how about the end of
a song now this is an asteroid that
would be about a couple of blocks a
kilometer across so think of it as the
size of a small mountain or
you know maybe three or four of these
city blocks here something like that
five city blocks
I don't care where on earth that hits
that is the end of humanity that is the
end of human civilization everything
that we have worked for not us just us
but us our predecessors our ancestors
and everything and all future
generations are gone that is the end of
it and nobody disputes that that is
that's something like 40 Giga tons of
energy that's multiple times larger than
all nuclear weapons ever built swell
think of setting off every nuclear
weapon ever built multiplied by a bunch
that's the kind of scale that you would
get doesn't matter where on the planet
that hits by the way that's the end of
us all point zero zero one percent okay
so my first goal in this talk is
actually to scare the pants off you so
you know why do we take this risk what I
want to show you is that we can actually
do something about it so but first I
thought it would be useful to show you
what the solar system looks like because
AI think this video is cool and it was
produced by our friends at the
California Academy of Sciences by the
way and what we're doing is I'm showing
you every single known asteroid in our
solar system so we have and the outer
part of this is the asteroid belt and
all these are correct orbits by the way
these are all plotted accurately we
don't care about the asteroid belt
because those asteroids can never hit
the earth they're out there beyond Mars
between Mars and Jupiter the light green
line is the orbit of Earth you can see
Venus and Mercury in between and these
are the ten thousand asteroids whose
orbits cross Earth's orbit that means
they can hit Earth
we call these near-earth asteroids
because they come near Earth very
creative and there are ten thousand of
them that nASA has found through a
program called Spaceguard wonderful
program they found ten thousand of these
asteroids here's the problem we know how
many asteroids they are we can count
craters you can also tell how what the
real solar must really look like because
we've only really observed some tiny
fraction sky it looks like this there's
about a million of them out there that
are large enough to take out a major
city so larger than the one in 1908
that's really what the solar system
looks like
and what we've done we've just
multiplied the distribution by 100 and
you can see that we in some sense you
can think of this as a giant cosmic
shooting gallery and when I said that
you know we are playing roulette every
day with our own civilization it's it's
really true so I want to let you in on a
secret which is that in two easy steps
you can actually prevent this okay I and
uh so what do you do about it okay the
two easy steps you can go to a cocktail
party sometime this weekend and tell
people I know how to protect the Earth
because there are two only two steps
detect and deflect okay even right we
made it rhyme for you so you can
remember it detect and deflect and what
that means is that you find them figure
out where they all are
and then deflect anything that's going
to hit us right simple right who here
believes that this is difficult okay
well a space technology is kind of
difficult at some level who here
believes step two is the hard part
you've seen Armageddon and you've seen
things like that right here's the
surprising part
step two is almost trivially easy
compared to step one we can do step two
we know how to do step two we've done
something very similar to this we know
how to do it step one is the problem we
don't know where the asteroids are
because think about it if you don't know
where asteroids are you can't deflect
them right if you don't know what's
coming your way it's like a baseball
batter with his eyes closed right how do
you know where to swing you don't so
step one is the hard part and actually
technically harder so that's the little
surprising fact is that deflecting
asteroids is relatively easy you know on
a large space mission scale of things so
so how do you deflect an asteroid simple
the first thing you have to understand
in order to understand how to deflect
asteroids is that from very very far
away it is extraordinarily difficult to
hit something that's moving
now the earth is going around the Sun
we're all traveling right now about
sixty five thousand miles an hour we go
around the Sun we travel about six
hundred million miles every year okay
remember those orbits of those asteroids
traveling also around the Sun let's say
an asteroid is going to hit the earth in
ten years okay that asteroid has roughly
six billion miles to go before it hits
the moving target of Earth that's a very
difficult shot so what does it take to
disrupt that ten years beforehand not
very much this is really a timing issue
now the earth being about eight thousand
miles across and moving at sixty-five
thousand miles an hour travels a
distance equal to its size in about
eight minutes
seven 1/2 minutes and that means that if
you should you can make that asteroid
show up to the intersection where it's
gonna hit the earth three minutes early
or three minutes late it doesn't hit the
earth right because the Earth's a moving
target
so really the game boils down to how do
I make an asteroid that's going it's got
six billion miles to go show up to that
same spot I don't have to change its
trajectory much but show up three
minutes early or three minutes late ten
years from now and that doesn't take
much and I'll get specific with you
again these typical speed of these
things 62 a hundred thousand miles an
hour if you change the speed of an
asteroid by about one millimeters per
second to give an example if you go
outside you know look in your look on
the ground find an ant walking they walk
about a millimeter per se a little bit
faster like a fast ant a running ant can
cover a few millimeters per second so
think about half or a third the speed of
an ant if you change the speed of an
asteroid traveling sixty five thousand
miles an hour by that amount it's gonna
miss the earth ten years from now it's
actually pretty easy here's the problem
you need ten years advance notice to do
that right but it turns out that's
actually what you're gonna what you get
so how do you make an asteroid some big
giant rock the size of this room change
its speed by the speed that an ant walks
simple basic physics tells you if I run
into it with a small the small
spacecraft I'll actually move it
slightly right so all you have to do is
basically Ram it
first thing you can do is this is called
a kinetic impactor which means it has
kinetic energy and it impacts it so hold
on let me back that up
don't know why that did that but so this
is just a video of a small tiny
spacecraft on its way towards an
asteroid and instead of putting on the
brakes before you get there you just run
into it we've actually done this in 2004
with that mission called deep impact we
ran into a comet
there's also a movie by the name of deep
impact and it did change the velocity of
that comment that's all it takes now
there are occasions when you need to
adjust the speed of an asteroid by a
precise amount to keep it from returning
back and to do that you can do something
called a gravity tractor so it's
something that me and a colleague came
up with some years back but all you
really need to do is hover a small
spacecraft that's what the spacecraft
looks like and there's an in the insert
but there it is hovering next to a
rotating asteroid and the tiny tiny
force of gravity if you hover near it
for a period of a few months is enough
to change it by a fraction of a
millimeter per second you can finally
adjust this even so not only can you do
this sort of simply you can also do it
accurately and and this by the way it
was from a simulation that we did at the
Jet Propulsion lab with an actual
spacecraft model and the dynamical model
of a real asteroid and so on and it
turns out to not actually be that
difficult of a mission it is
considerably simpler than landing a SUV
size Rover on Mars for instance so we
can do this but again we keep coming
back to we have to find the asteroids
first there's about a million asteroids
out there that are large enough to do
great damage on this planet we found
about 10,000 how do we find the other
99% that is the entire problem right now
and so we're doing just that our
foundation it's called the b612
foundation long story if anybody wants
to ask I'll tell you what what where
that comes from but we spent the number
of years looking at the problem s or a
deflection step to
and we came to the conclusion as did the
rest of the community that the
deflection is actually doable about two
years ago I gave a talk back at at
Google where I used to work and I
described how we knew how to do to
deflect asteroids but we really had no
hope of deflecting the great majority of
them because we don't know where they
are
we haven't tracked them yet and I know
it's sort of describing the sad state of
affairs and how the government wasn't
doing anything at the time you know for
a host of reasons the government budget
battles weren't allowing this to happen
it didn't fit neatly into the science
missions at NASA and so on and basically
I left it sort of on a low note and at
the end of the talk this guy came up to
me and he says to me oh well how much
would it cost to actually go ahead and
find all those asteroids you know how to
do that right I said well yeah there's a
particular kind of telescope that you
need to build and so on which I'll tell
you about but he said oh how much would
that cost to build a spacecraft like
that I said well if you didn't have to
do it through government contracting if
you just knew they knew the right people
if you if you could go directly towards
starting the project and so on you could
do this pretty efficiently you know in
in five years or so you could put this
thing together for a few hundred million
dollars which spacecraft standards is
moderate it's a ton of money though and
and he says oh okay
he goes so why don't you just do it and
I thought to myself you know eh you're
crazy and B what do you mean just do it
so I basically said what do you mean why
don't I go just do it he goes oh why
don't you just raise the money and do it
and he go then he continued and he said
you know what I am a member of the San
Francisco Museum of Modern Art and we're
building a new addition to the the
museum no it's a wonderful museum and
you know probably who here's been to
that Museum great place by the way my
sister sitting there did build that
building so
but they're rebuilding it now they're
putting a new addition on it and he goes
and we are raising at the time he said
400 million I know understand it's up to
550 million we're raising five hundred
you know five hundred million or so to
build the new edition of the of an art
museum and it's just the people of San
Francisco we're gonna come together and
we're gonna do this we're going to build
this beautiful building for the people
of San Francisco for the next you know
50 years or whatnot the people San
Francisco will have this museum to enjoy
it's a wonderful thing and and he goes
think about that he goes so you're
telling me that if we can raise five
hundred million dollars to build an
addition to an art museum that you can't
raise less than that to save the world
and you really got me thinking so I'm
driving home and I'm thinking to myself
yeah that's crazy and he goes yeah yeah
and you know he actually went on and
told me a little bit about how people
raise money for things like you know
museums or universities raise money for
you know new chemistry buildings or
whatnot and he goes oh there's hundreds
of projects this size most of them are
larger actually going on any given time
the United States and he turned out to
be right so I'm driving home and finally
I get to my driveway and I just decided
I was gonna call it rusty Schweickart
and so I call him on my cell phone I'm
sitting out there in my driveway and I
said rusty you know and I told him the
story of what this guy said and I go I
think we got to do this and he goes and
rusty and in his own he goes you know
who's a for those who know him he's a
he's a crotchety guy rusty goes I think
you're right I think this is what we
need to do and that was the sort of
turning point this was less than two
years ago
and we decided to go do just that so
we're raising the money we're building a
space telescope
it's called Sentinel I'll show you what
it looks like this is it it's a lot
bigger than that it is roughly the size
of this ceiling so if you look up to the
top there to the floor that's about the
height of it it's an infrared Space
Telescope because asteroids are very
very dark they're almost a color of
charcoal and that means that they're
very very difficult to spot from the
ground
they're small in the dark and out there
in space far away millions of miles from
the earth and that's why we've only
found 1% of them but if they're small
but but if they're dark they're warmed
by the Sun and they glow in infrared
so what we're building this Space
Telescope is actually an infrared Space
Telescope so you can think of that as
something like the world's largest pair
of night-vision goggles
and it will spot these things you can
see asteroids from great distances and
they stand out like sore thumbs against
the dark background sky in infrared
furthermore you want to put this
satellite in a particular location you
don't want it next to the earth because
then you can only look outwards from the
earth you cannot look inwards towards
the Sun you know any kid will tell you
that if you want to look at stars you
don't go out in the middle of the day
and look towards the Sun right you look
good at night so it's gonna we're gonna
place into an orbit around the Sun near
the orbit of the planet Venus and see
that white swath that is the area that
it can see the light green line is the
Earth's orbit and it will actually scan
Earth's orbit and over a period of years
it's actually going to find and track
all these asteroids that could that
could hit Earth and will give us the
decades of warning we need to employ the
easy step step 2 so getting back to how
or do we protect our planet you know
there's really a you know you can think
of a detect deflect defend all begins
with a letter D and here's how I
actually think this is going to play out
by the way in we are launching in 2018
we're gonna launch from Cape Canaveral
aboard SpaceX Falcon 9 rocket and we are
going to deploy and within six and a
half years we'll basically complete this
map of the asteroids in our solar system
and that'll be step one what if we find
one that's going to hit the earth and
and by the way I can tell you the
chances we're gonna find one remember
the I told you that there's a 30% chance
this century that's there's going to be
an asteroid that's going to hit the
earth well that means we have a 30%
chance of finding an asteroid that's
going to hit the earth right because
there's a 30% chance that there is one
all right
and so this is actually pretty likely
right so you can look forward to in the
next decade or so an announcement that
an asteroid is going to hit the earth on
a certain time date in place we can
track things very very accurately we can
actually tell you down to sort of the
fraction of a second and within a few
kilometers of where that thing is going
to hit and now how do we generate the
funds to pay to deflect it okay I submit
that that is not a problem and that's
because that's landing on somebody's
house or at least somebody's
congressional district right it is ad
well defined threat and that is
something that our governments are very
good at handling all right our
governments are not good at handling the
probabilistic long term threats
step one and that's where the private
organizations come in like us the
nonprofit's like long now we are raising
this money philanthropic we and we're
going to give the data out to the world
so that everyone gets the warning and
step two will happen I have full
confidence that step two will happen if
they if we know that something is going
to hit us and step three I call it
defend but really this is actually kind
of the interesting thing as you get
philosophical about these things I think
actually step three is the enormous
party that you throw afterwards and I
say that kind of facetiously but it's
actually true if you think about it
that's going to be a unifying event in
world history up until this time for the
last four billion years on this planet
the third planet from the Sun this plan
has been hit repeatedly by large
asteroids okay that process should stop
from this point on unless we get hit
before we do before we deploy our
satellite Sentinel from that point on we
should not be hit by asteroids anymore
if we do our job so you know what are
the way I look at this as is our gift to
future generations that we are going to
stop this process okay and you know
basically that's also our gift to our
donors you know they become the heroes
you get to save the earth
and so there's there's something in it
for them which is the knowledge of
knowing that they actually did something
to change and protect the future of the
entire planet which is very empowering
which is I think personally why our
donors have stepped up to doing this so
in the end that's what this is what it's
all about is protecting this particular
spaceship and I think that you know when
I when I think about the things that you
know I think about how lucky I am I've
had the opportunity to do some really
cool things courtesy of the US taxpayer
thank you very much but right now I feel
luckier than ever because I get to try
and save the planet for real and that is
an incredible gift that is a incredible
opportunity it's one you can't turn down
it's one that if you're lucky in your
entire life you'll get a chance to do
that right so I feel very very lucky so
I would like to end it here and switch
to question and answer so thank you for
your attention and I will answer
anything about any question you've got
so thank you very much
[Applause]
it's great Thank You Stuart
have a seat great picture huh it seldom
looks like that doesn't it I mean that's
a very rare place to get that so the Sun
right exactly behind the can exactly
this mm-hmm I think the thing that's you
know I used to curate photographs of the
earth and the thing at all shocked
people is it was mostly a crescent most
of the time I don't you don't get the
full earth view Plus weirdly enough
North is not up it's just yeah wherever
you are is out right have to do is turn
the camera yes well let's go Kevin
Kelly's happens to be on top here
how many world war sized asteroids have
hit the earth in the last two thousand
years okay so let's do a little math all
right it's always dangerous as they say
to do math in public okay but every
10,000 years you know if it's one
percent per century that means there
were roughly every ten thousand years we
are hit by an asteroid of that size so
human civilization is roughly ten
thousand years old right so in the last
two thousand years it's like there's
only a 20% chance that there's been one
but it's possible and it likely would
have landed in the ocean it's likely the
legend of a great flood okay if an
asteroid that size hit us 10,000 years
ago frankly it's not that big of a deal
because we didn't have an interconnected
Society we didn't have you know global
transport networks global monetary
networks or things like that we had no
YouTube most importantly and so nobody
would have found out about it you might
maybe you've killed off you wipe out a
bunch of fishing villages today that's
not the case question from Cameron
Woodward will the foundation be working
with private space exploration companies
to address this issue what can I do
right now to help okay well we are a
private thank you we are a private
organization we are partnered however
with NASA no I don't want to bash them
because they are partners of ours NASA
does want to get this data they do want
to do the right thing
Washington sometimes doesn't allow that
so we went to NASA with a great deal we
said look we're gonna go do this we'll
give the data out
how would you like to have the data and
they said we would love to have the data
we would like to put it on our website
and put it on you know disturbing it to
scientists around the world okay and we
haven't asked it goes we need to
transmit our data back through antennas
on the ground and you have antennas on
the ground that do just that
we don't want to build another set they
said you can use ours it's called the
Deep Space Network so you know we are
this didn't some sense already it's a
public-private partnership now as to
what you can do you know I have to plug
our websites b612 foundation org and you
can sign up to get you know information
on what's going on we have regular
progress updates and so on and or you
can donate you know and in the end it's
our donors that are making this happen
Andres can you tell us in morbid detail
exactly what happens gonna plan that
killer hits oh I can tell you a little
bit about the asteroid that wiped out
the dinosaurs it's pretty interesting I
didn't bring it with me but I actually
have a little chunk of what's called the
KT boundary it's a it's a layer of rock
that if you go anywhere in the world I
don't care what continent and you're on
if you dig down to the right depth you
will find a layer of rock with a layer
of ash in the middle which was very very
thick at one point then was crushed down
to form a layer of rock about yay thick
and it was laid down on over a period of
a couple days when the whole earth
burned what actually happened is if you
look at the energy of an asteroid that
size which landed in the Yucatan
Peninsula it threw up enough molten rock
out of the crater which is about a
hundred some-odd miles across and it's
about 30 or 40 miles deep and if you do
the math you know PI R squared times the
depth love did you math in public and
you know you you're talking hundreds of
thousands of cubic miles of molten rock
where does it go goes up into space and
then it comes back down all around the
globe and if you look at the energy of
that hitting the atmosphere a couple
hundred thousand cubic miles of rock
hitting the atmosphere you find that the
atmosphere ends up about five hundred
degrees for a few hours so what that
means is that everything catches fire
and everything burned that day which is
why we have no more dinosaurs there are
dinosaur fossils below this and none
above this we basically burned
everything that could on the whole
planet
over period of probably a couple days
what happened to the oceans at that not
that much which is why many species
survived under puddles under rocks
little furry creatures that became
humans eventually and so that's the sort
of gory detail of it but that shouldn't
happen anymore
great details what happened in idle in
my personal feelings right it's a big
rock like that really hard to nudge or
they did arbitrary well you get you get
a one benefit from this big rocks tend
to be easier to spot you tend to get
longer notice so the longer away
something is from hitting the less you
need to nudge it so the fact that it's
bigger is offset somewhat by the fact
that you in general will get a longer
notice again unless one of these things
is on its way in the next you know a
couple of decades and we're just slow
and putting up our telescope in that
case then you just end up with this
situation where there's nothing you can
do and then we can make some bad movies
about it and stuff but um you it is
within our capability to do that now it
it wouldn't be a single mission you may
have to fly you know ten missions or
something like that but again I think if
the earth is going to end we will find
the funding to send ten missions up
there speed gory details you see exactly
what happened with that recent Siberian
[Music]
meteorites whose ear was on watching
YouTube on February 15th anybody see
Russian dash cams
okay um the there was a small asteroid
about fifty feet across so that is would
easily fit inside this round so and it
landed about the distance from here to
you know let's say let's say you
Chelyabinsk in San Francisco it landed
somewhere around Sacramento okay
so it's pretty far away and it was
coming in a very shallow angle which
meant that it's shockwave actually
wasn't headed down the shockwave was
headed sideways and that is why the city
of Chelyabinsk the residents of
Chaldeans got very lucky all it did was
blow out a hundred thousand windows and
send 2,000 people
because it was you know 4050 miles away
from the city and it very high altitude
going sideways
had it been closer to the city or been
coming down we would you could have had
a million casualties the explosive
energy of that impact was about 30 times
the bomb used over her Oshima so it was
pretty big you know again small rock you
know fits inside here moving at you know
40,000 miles an hour has a lot of energy
and so these the couple these things are
basically atmosphere impacts I mean both
of the Siberian events yes the rock
didn't hit the ground and caused a
problem they hit the atmosphere and
caused approaches and in fact you often
get more damage when you burst in the
air this is something they actually knew
at the time of you know in World War two
they often blow up bombs that you drop
in the air because they cause more
damage when they blow up in the air than
they do if they hit the ground question
from Peter Schwartz what's the object
hitted tortoise is a comet like deep
impact hard to predict the course harder
to do something about it comets are an
interesting and unsolved problem
comets are different than asteroids and
that instead of orbiting the Sun in
clothes like us they come from the far
far far out reaches way out you know
many times the distance of Pluto so you
can't spot them out there because
they're really cold out there and so
they don't glow in infrared very well
you can pick them up at some level but
it's very very hard they come screaming
in at high speed they go zipping around
and they go ahead back on they disappear
again not to come back for perhaps you
know decades or even hundreds of years
and that means that you basically don't
get to map those things very easily we
don't have the technology to do that so
we currently don't have the technology
to stop a comet but I'm not going to let
this stop us from solving the problem of
asteroids because there are roughly a
hundred times more asteroids than
comments and there's a lot of problems I
don't know how to solve global warming
you know poverty education and comets
and but the one problem that I do know
how to solve is asteroids so that's what
I'm going to
nothing not that we shouldn't solve it
but it is a smaller problem numerically
- are there historically or looking at
the moon surface have there been common
impacts that you can detect as being
such know the difference between a
common impact and an asteroid impact is
likely to from point of view of the
crater not much and those speeds you
know ice rock doesn't matter what it is
when you're moving you know forty or
fifty thousand miles an hour mm-hmm
doesn't you know leaves a big hole and I
think we saw one of the gas planets was
a Jupiter or Saturn had a Jupiter was
hit yeah tell about that one yes it was
about fifteen years ago
mm-hmm we had that was a cometary
fragment that was captured by by Jupiter
and was predicted ahead of time they
actually spotted it before it hit
Jupiter by a woman named Carolyn
shoemaker and uh and a guy named David
Levy and they actually gave advance
warning and we actually got incredible
images of this thing that the chunks
were about a mile across or so or
something like that it was interesting
because they left these scars on the
planet roughly each of which was roughly
the size the planet Earth
so you know you don't want to get hit by
these things again I stress my feeling
is we should not be hit by these things
that's a pretty big I remember the
images of it's been hitting the yeah if
you draw the earth scale next to that
you can find that those things are the
size of the earth okay I want to leave
this is a hopeful message because we can
do something about it
here here Danielle asks are asteroids
potentially useful to what we know them
about the my noble resources
technologies developing coming for
asteroid mining there seems to be a
private company who wants you mine
asteroids how does that relate to all
those asteroids potentially could be
someday a source of resources for use in
space now we have no idea how we're
going to do that you some space not on
earth Oh likely because it's bringing
things like or back is very very
difficult likely they're talking about
use in space now we don't have any idea
how to do that but I can tell you step
one find them it's exactly the same you
can't mind an asteroid if you don't know
where it is alright you can't deflect it
either but all of those companies have
exactly the same problem that they only
know where 1% of the asteroids are with
your with Sentinel will you be able to
some of the asteroids are really kind
valuable in terms a lot of metal and
stuff like that and a lot of them are
pretty worthless rock and you know
goodness gravel I guess will Sentinel be
able to tell the difference between them
is there mass make them Sentinel will
not be able to tell the difference
between them by itself ok but this is
actually an interesting problem the we
have lots of telescopes with very high
magnification that can tell that you
have to do what's called spectroscopy
now the the telescopes that can find out
what the composition of an asteroid are
have very very small fields of views
it's like looking through a soda straw
ok so they need to know where to point
to find asteroids you want to be able to
see the whole sky alright to determine
what's in a particular asteroid you want
to look at it through a soda straw at
high magnification like the Hubble Space
Telescope so what we will actually do is
tell people where all the asteroids are
and then you can point these other
telescopes and find out what the
individual asteroid
made out of once you tell him where to
point um Dan Haley asked how many years
in advance can you predict the path of
an asteroid and with what kind of
precision precision is actually very
very good
and typically we should get be able to
give warning of about you know up to
about a hundred years if before an
asteroid hits us and so to give you an
idea of the kind of tracking accuracy
that we have you know consider that we
landed that Martian Rover in the central
part of a crater slightly off to one
side near the central peak you know on
purpose right so we on Mars
okay and that required you know we knew
where to send that that vehicle years
ahead of time before we even launched it
we knew where we're sending it right it
was in a computer file somewheres right
but that's exactly the same process by
which real track asteroids you know so
when we find one that's going to hit the
earth you actually know where it's gonna
hit and win there's a question here do
they ever hit each other and sort of
deflect their paths because ever hit
each other no they do on occasion and
because of the larger asteroids have
craters on them but it's pretty rare
because these are these are small you
know they the the likeliest way an
asteroid is gonna die is not by hitting
another asteroid it's by hitting a
planet which is much larger and so the
planets tend to suck em up and planet
shins took them in all right yes exactly
when rusty talked to nine years ago he
said that part of detection and getting
a fix on the trackers and it wasn't
really going to be a collision path that
you would want to put some kind of a tag
on the asteroid yeah okay it's called
the transponder and I think it's likely
so what's what's gonna happen is this
we're gonna find an asteroid we're gonna
say we're gonna track it for some period
of time we're gonna say hey this one's
got a very good chance of hitting the
earth or or this one is actually going
to hit the earth you want to be really
darn sure and one of the things we're
likely to do is to put get an
independent means of measuring its
position just to put next to it a small
spacecraft it could be a gravity tractor
you could also tow it with the same
spacecraft
at the same time if you need to but
we'll also add some accuracy to the the
positioning because when you can think
of it as a homing beacon
you know it'll have a radio transmitter
onboard and when you put it next to this
to the asteroid you launch up to it and
you bring it close by will then be able
to measure precisely using our ground
telescopes our ground antennas its
position and we'll be able so I think
before you you would likely do this
ahead of time to increase your accuracy
again you know if if we've got a giant
asteroid headed for San Francisco we'll
do that you know cost of such a mission
might be a few hundred million but I
think it's worth it
and so it sounds like one of the things
you get was a transponder there is the
kind of accuracy it sounds like you
could actually see where it would hit on
the planet yeah more than just that I
mean you you you get a lot I mean you
can actually say where we'll hit based
without that mm-hmm but this one gives
you another further confidence level and
also it gives you the ability once you
deflect it to remeasure it to make sure
it worked
your deflection right you measure where
is it going interesting so what you do
is if you would back that spacecraft off
do your deflection and go back in
alright because I think everyone's gonna
want to know right away whether or not
it worked it works yes right because not
only you stay in the keyhole or
something like that trying to guess you
next time exactly what what Stuart's
talking about is something called a
keyhole which is this you know yeah we
deflected it oh no at Kemah comes back
and hits us again and and it turns out
that if you just miss a planet just go
grazing past it the earth or the
whatever that planet is will change the
trajectory of an asteroid no anybody
here who studied orbital mechanics and I
don't know if there is anybody besides
me but if you did you would know that
orbits do come back to the same place
okay so it is possible that all you have
done is delayed the impact by a couple
of years that's called a return key halt
you want you need to prevent that before
you do a premature celebration of number
three that you display it so that we
again this is something we understand I
still lump that into the the easier half
of things right and the isaacsohn s
by publishing asteroid locations you
will enable asteroid mining private
ventures is this a good bad and
different and or illegal prospect and or
is it a business model
I think I'm happy to enable scientific
missions commercial missions exploration
missions all of those things and I think
we should you know I look at it as our
our you know our contribution is to
provide that you can think of this as a
map of the solar system right you know
what are the what is the first thing you
do before you explore a continent you
map it right what did Lewis and Clark do
they mapped the interior part of the of
the of North America alright so that you
could go you could go do these things
and I think that's a great thing again I
can't emphasize enough that right now
nobody has any credible means of mining
an asteroid but someday in the future I
believe we will for what what would we
use a mind asteroid for space I think
the like is likeliest thing is rocket
fuel rocket fuel is water because if you
break it up it's hydrogen oxygen which
is what we use to power space shuttle
and I think rocket fuel will be that the
thing because the majority of what
Rockets carry up is actually their fuel
and someday when we have an economy that
exists more than just on the earth and I
believe we will someday as long as we
don't get wiped out by an asteroid
someday this is some day this century or
I would not bet against it mm-hm
you know I think you know you it's
always been a losing bet to bet against
peoples and geo Andes and against you
know to say that you know all will never
be able to do that in X number of years
that's always been a losing proposition
to make statements like that so I won't
be of weird things of gravity tractor is
you know if we've walked enough tractor
beams in enough movies do you think yeah
right see a little bit about why a
gravity tractor and what it what's
actually going on here okay
gravity tractor so myself and my
colleague at another astronaut named
Stan Love who has a PhD so he's dr. love
we came up with this idea in 2004 I
think it was because the problem with
trying to put an engine on an asteroid
to move it is that they're spinning
asteroids right and if you have an
engine this point you know even if you
attach it to things spinning you're not
going anywheres right it's like the
balloon that you let go right just goes
around an old circle right and asteroid
surfaces are crumbly and so on so you we
were trying to figure out a way to move
them without actually touching and we
realized that you only need to apply a
tiny amount of force the amount of force
that you need to lift up like a stack of
cards because if you apply this amount
of force over a period of months that
actually adds up you ever been on stood
along a dock and tried to pull a boat
into a dock you know you got a rope on
it and you're in your pull pull pull
pull pull pull it looks like it's not
doing anything but if you just sit there
and just pull on it for about a minute
or two at some point you realize it's
starting to move the same principle the
the what's known as the impulse is the
product of how long you push for it
times the force you push for so even
though the force is small if you do it
for months or years at a time you can
actually see move significant size
objects and it turns out that anything
near a massive asteroid there's a force
of attraction between them it's gravity
and in order to stay there you can have
rocket thrusters that could push to keep
you away from the asteroid but if the
thrusters point out you're actually
pushing the asteroid away from you but
if you can't your thrusters out like
this and then the rocket plumes don't
hit the asteroid and you hold position
you can just sort of tow it and that's
it turns out to be actually a fairly
simple spacecraft ability and are you
typically gonna want to go in the
orbital path you wanted to deflect it
sort of a path or just make it go slower
or faster basically you want to make an
asteroid go slower or faster and because
it's the whole thing of upsetting the
timing taking advantage of the fact that
the earth is a moving target so you're
really not going to move its path very
much at all you're going to adjust the
timing
so the rear-ending stories are all about
speeding it up yeah or or you can get
you can get in the way and let it hit
you and slow it down - that also works
so you can hit on either side or tow it
in either direction and you know in
particular situation any particular
reason to choose speeding it up you're
slowing
yeah usually the thing that will
determine whether or not you speed an
asteroid up or slow it down depends upon
the orbital make the launch opportunity
you get to send something there because
you it turns out that usually there will
be one good way to come in towards it
because you're going or go around the
Sun and getting it - getting it to meet
up with it you know either on the front
side of the backside will usually
determine it but you can also have
geopolitical considerations because if
an asteroid is going to hit the earth
and you move it one way and but you
don't move it far enough you you can
shift it in one direction versus the
other direction so rusty Schweickart
talks about this issue which way do you
push it turns out though that in many
many cases if not most cases you really
can only push in one direction because
you don't have a launch opportunity in
the other direction so it may in many
cases you just end up being able to push
in one direction only because you don't
I don't have a good orbit that takes me
from Earth to the asteroid within a set
amount of time that that it's moving
faster than in the same position is it
or slower than it say more about launch
opportunities these are called launch
windows mm-hmm
and people are familiar with it for
instance like because let's say the
Earth and Mars right they're both going
around the Sun the Earth's going around
once a year Mars it's something like 18
months and so they're both going around
at different speeds
you can't launch at any given time from
here and make it to this moving target
over here because you you need to have a
path that takes you basically Europe
you're gonna put your spacecraft into an
orbit itself that has to catch up with
another object so that is why when we
launch to Mars we haven't what it's
called a launch we know every 26 months
so there are launch windows for reaching
asteroids too and they depend entirely
upon what the orbit of that asteroid is
so that it's not as simple as Mars but
there are only certain times you can
launch I can see this would be another
element of you would like as much
advance notice as possible you have a
committee or some things that it's
already too late you're hired
you get it yes the longer in general you
have to do this allows you a bunch of
number one the less you need to move the
asteroid number two the more
opportunities you have for Plan B if
something happens and and C you know
launch Windows become easier so so again
my friend Don Yeomans who's a at the Jet
Propulsion lab he says there's three
rules for different of what makes
asteroid deflection easy he goes he goes
there's three things you got to have
it's like it's like the three rules of
real estate so it's find them early find
them early and find them early you know
so and that's really true how early is
plausible there must be a certain amount
of fuzz even in orbital mechanics yeah
the kind of with the kind of accuracy
that we have with sentinel the typical
time you're gonna give is multiple
decades multiple decades yes so you
shouldn't say me thirty years yes you
should not think of the warning that
you're gonna get as oh this thing is
gonna hit us next week and we have to
blow it up you know right again
don't think blowing up anyhow but you
should be thinking Oh on I'm just making
this date you know April 18th
you know 2046 at 7:23 in the morning in
this city there's gonna be an impact
what are we gonna do and we've got 30
years you should be that's the way that
it's gonna look like and that's what
allows you to the chance to methodically
do step two that's an astonishing amount
of precision a little very long time in
advance it is I'll use another example
the kind of precision that nASA has
developed in I guess it was about seven
or eight years ago we landed a probe on
Titan on the shore of a lake of a moon
of Saturn on purpose so we have this
kind of precision you know isn't you
know it isn't math and astronomy
incredible yeah
boring actually and compared to biology
where you never know what the hell is
going on boring its precision I'll just
Kevin Kelly always talks about
unattended benefits so you get Sentinel
going and it's there dutifully watching
further threatening asteroids what else
is it gonna find it might be of interest
yeah we've been talking to a lot of our
astronomer friends and it turns out what
we're actually finding is objects the
very end brightness either because
they're moving or because they're
varying in brightness so that you know
what will we find out there I don't
actually know yet because this isn't a
range this range of the infrared
spectrum that's between four and ten
microns for anybody who cares is one
that is not well explored at all because
we're building the first large-scale
detector in this frequency range and the
history of astronomy is that whenever
you open up a brand new frequency range
to observe things say in x-rays or
infrared or microwave and whatnot you
always find something surprising and in
fact the great advances in astronomy
have always happened because we've
opened up a brand-new observing range
with our telescopes we're gonna do the
same what are we gonna find I don't know
III look forward to it because I'm sure
we're gonna find some interesting things
and I'm sure that you know in the end
when we look back at what what the
contribution of Sentinel is besides
saving the world there's going to be
incredible science too and I think that
you know you also again if I know where
the asteroids are going to hit the earth
I also know the ones who know near the
earth and therefore can be reached by
exploration missions and by robotic
scientific probes too because again
right now we know of ten thousand
asteroids we're gonna know of a million
asteroids when this is all done I'm sure
that there are thousands of interesting
ones out there and many of them are
going to come close to the earth so by
the way whenever you read or hear in the
news or you know see on TV that an
asteroid is whizzed past the earth you
know and there was one about two weeks
ago on the 31st
think to yourself ah for everyone that
we know about there's 99 more that we
never knew about because that's that's
the case now the one on the 31st by the
way was about two and a half kilometers
across I think something like that and
so that would that falls into the wipe
us all out category they know about that
one yeah we knew about that one we knew
it wasn't gonna hit us and only missed
us by about three million miles which is
you know in cosmically speaking actually
mmm reasonably close not that close but
but you know think about it what if that
thing had been honest towards hitting us
and we and let's say you only had a
year's notice there's nothing you can do
that would be the end of us that was
that one was large enough to take us all
out take all of humanity out alright
schedule I get a certain sense of
urgency now getting Sentinel up happen
we are launching Sentinel in 2018 and
our current plan is actually at July
20th launch of 2018 I love July 20th
date which is because of a launch window
towards Venus will use the gravity of
Venus to pull us in orbit around the Sun
but I love it because that's also the
anniversary of the first moon landing
okay and to get from here to there so
you've got Sentinel designed is that
right yeah we we have sort of eight
major milestones towards the launch
these are what are known as the
technical reviews in which you button
everything up with each stage of design
and we've been through the first one
we're heading towards the second one
which will be in November the eighth
milestone is actually we're lighting the
fuse to launch it into space
so that'll put us at about the quarter
way point when we by November let's talk
money two hundred million dollars that's
still sort of the rough number large
eternal realities roughly what the
spacecraft costs you have to add in
operations yeah add in Mission Control
you have to add in a rocket all this
other stuff okay so it's about double
that
and you're not raising 200 million or
300 million whatever it'll be right now
how much we're raising now well like any
project you raise what you need for the
next milestone you know so our current
milestone this year our goal is 20
million mm-hmm okay and that that keeps
us towards milestone 2 and so if anybody
out here has to check for 20 million you
can see Danika here or Karen over there
for that amount they get a naming
opportunity or yesterday we will name
anything Danica has two sons she's
willing to change their names where does
the federal government cut in if ever I
mean this thing is certainly the way
sort of explaining at the beginning is
that you're going to travel government
is not stepping up and so private sector
can do this really hard detect part of
knowing that somebody else will step up
one so there's something that you defend
from but is this gonna be b612 all the
way in to orbit or current currently the
things cut in there are some interesting
discussions going on which I can't
really talk about publicly but you know
there are there is interest and was
sparked because of an asteroid impact
over Russia hmm and the ensuing
congressional hearings where the head of
Space Command general Shelton the head
of NASA Charlie Bolden and the head of
the president's science advisor John
Holdren were up in front of Congress and
I was too and they were asked did you
see this asteroid coming and the answer
was no no and no why not because we're
not looking for it we're not looking for
it and we're not looking for it and how
are you going to find the next one and
the reply from general Shelton was my
stuff looks down not up Charlie Bolden
and John Holdren both said the b612
foundation is going to do that for us
the natural question that arose is oh
when I got up there so you're going to
find these asteroids for us right and we
said yes and they said are we supporting
you
we said well you know you're
congratulating us and you are and you
know and we have an agreement to
transmit our data through your and they
said how much money are we giving you I
said nothing they said what we need to
talk and so there are discussions things
move slow in Washington but this really
gets to the point of at some level
protecting you know us providing for the
common defense right is a governmental
role right and there's two ways of
looking at this you can either say well
they ought to do that we gotta send an
army of lobbyists and we gotta figure
out a way to get this to happen amidst
our current budgetary environment or you
can just do it right and so I mean I
look at this as being a case where I
think and I'm not sure how this is all
gonna play out but you know there are
many cases where the government leads
and private citizens following there are
some cases where the private citizens
leads and governments fall I think this
is like you're gonna be one of those
cases factum I should point out Karen
Putnam over there who is with b612
Foundation now Karen for those who don't
know her previously was the you were the
president of Central Park Conservancy
correct and for that she raised the
money if for those who remember about I
think was about 15 years ago or so you
you raised the hundred million dollars
plus to renovate and fix up Central Park
which was sorely in need of it and Karen
tells us I'll paraphrase your words that
the thing that they had to go they went
to private citizens to do this and
remember that Park is a public park the
city of New York owned and operated it
right owns and operates it but they
didn't have the money to fix it up and
it was falling apart right and you could
come whine and complain that the the
city wasn't doing its job to upkeep the
public property for everybody in New
York or the private citizens could step
up and just do it and you know in
conjunction with the city and you know
that's why she's perfect for for our
organization because
we have a very similar story you know
this in the end I think yeah and this is
the empowering part of this is that
people in private individuals can start
the ball rolling we can even finish it
you know the government choose to get
involved and we may work with them on
that but right now we are solely
supported by private donations
well you mentioned at the beginning as a
sort of veteran of the shuttle and space
science and all that that you thought
that non government could move more
quickly and more surely in terms of
design and construction and the costs
and schedule and so on see a little more
about that yeah I was uh you know I was
part of NASA for 12 years I've been
involved in aerospace related things for
now almost 20 years and I know the
inefficiencies we had and and a lot of
these innovations are driven by
government regulations which are there
to prevent people sending contracts to
friends and things like that all sorts
of good reasons you have government
regulations on these things but they
prevent you from doing things in the
most efficient way for anybody who's
here is ever held a government job knows
that we don't do things in the most
efficient way in the government we can
do big things but clearly not
efficiently so when we decided we were
going to do this I called up a guy named
Harold Reitsma who was a he came up this
idea at the infrared Space Telescope to
find asteroids and I said Harold you
know you you know you'd been pitching us
for a few years now and you know in a
perfect world how would you build this
project let's just say I had the funding
for it in a perfect world how would you
how would you do this he goes well you
know we would do it we would sign a
commercial contract for this instead of
a what are called cost plus contractors
so the government does things whatever
you say it cost you we add 5% in there's
your profit okay which works when you
don't know what you're gonna how you're
gonna do with you know you're doing
something extraordinarily difficult
that's the only way you can do it cuz
they have no idea what it's going to
cost them to do but with this one
because of the fact that we've built
some telescopes that are similar to this
we know how to do that
I would do that I would pick sort of the
10 best people in the world we all know
who they are
hmm we would hire them away and we would
have you know instead of a team of a
huge team we would have the 10 best
people in the world a small team and we
would do this we would build it around a
project not inordinate we're not trying
to build an organization we're trying to
carry out a project nature so you don't
you're not trying to build a legacy of a
building and it you know monument to
ourselves that sort of stuff you're
trying to get a project done and and you
could do this and you can cut the price
in half or less you don't have to get
parts from every constituency in them
you know who the right contractor is
it's a company called Ball Aerospace
they built the Kepler space telescope
and the Spitzer's infrared space
telescope which is the first infrared
space observatory they're the ones there
that all the ones who could do this and
we said well let's go to them and let's
let's go get this done so I said Harold
well that's what we want to do and he
and he said you know sign me up
so then we went to a guy named Scott
Harvard who used to run NASA Ames he for
those who follow NASA he was also the
person who rescued NASA's Mars program
he was what's called the Mars are about
1213 years ago so he ran all NASA's Mars
programs he's now a Stanford professor
called him up we met just like you know
typical Silicon Valley we met for lunch
down at the California cafe in Palo Alto
did the same thing with him I said Scott
in a perfect world how would you run
this this program and he said exactly
the same thing as Harold because he's
had the same experience as me and Harold
in these government-run programs he knew
what the inefficiencies were he said
well if I could do it I would hire these
people I would do it and I said well
that's what we're doing he said sign me
up we put together our list of the 10
people the best people in the world and
we hired them all that process only took
a few weeks the this the sales to each
of them was essentially the same hey
this is how we're doing it and they said
and every single one of them said I want
it and so you know that this mission of
saving the world and doing things the
way you've always wanted to do that
it was kind of irresistible another
thing that happens is when you go public
with something like this as a certain
dazzle factor people hear about it and
some interesting people just show up
maybe hit any of those what do you mean
by interesting people people with a you
know $20 check or people with skills or
context or rolodex rules yeah yeah I
mean the organization is going to take a
lot of different things besides just
building a spacecraft we are raising
funds we are spreading the word we have
a couple of our folks out here who will
help you know we're the ones who get the
word out on what we're doing which is
critical mm-hmm and you know and and
just keeping the organization running
and you know and they're down here
they're there all over the place and so
we have some really great folks I'm
really proud of the team because we're
small and we're focused you ever have
the phenomenon of people here that this
problem can be solved they sort of
relaxed because they figure it has been
so yeah there are people who think that
NASA already has this under control and
all I have to do is show them the
videotape of the congressional hearings
with the head of NASA saying nope we
didn't see it coming and saying well the
b612 foundation is going to do that and
you know III can't stress enough how
much of I consider heroes the folks who
didst who are stepping up and being
donors because they're the folks who say
well you know I can let out somebody
else do this or I can do it or I can
just step up and solve this problem
because you know this is this is the
crux of the issue right that's sort of
the converse of the the tragedy of the
Commons right or the inverse I don't
know what you want to call it but when
it's everybody's responsibility it's
nobody's responsibility right and you
know this is something also it for the
long now foundation right when when
something is everybody's responsibility
who's gonna get it done and that's where
you require the these heroes to step up
and say you know what I'm just yeah I
have been lucky enough to you know have
made some money and during my life and
now I want to just
make this happen and those are the
people are making it happen we're just
one spending it I think I hadn't thought
of this as a tragedy of the Commons kind
of deal but it really is and it it's an
interesting one because it's not only
space but also time and yeah this we're
discounting the future phenomenon it
occurred about the over cost overall
cost of it too you know in what global
world-changing problem can you solve I
mean just completely put to bed and
solve for the cost of building I like a
freeway overpass right and it is right
well I mean oh it's way less than the
Bay Bridge I heard somebody say that
it's it's probably the cost of the
repairs on the Bay Bridge right you know
what to fix what they screwed up right
but you know literally you know if the
city of San Francisco can build a you
know that that devil slide tunnel
project which cost way more than saving
the earth then why can't we go to the
citizens of the world and just do it
let's do it
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you